وأريد أن أشكركم جميعًا هنا
فرانك بما في ذلك المسؤولين المنتخبين من الحزبين
مثل نائب الحاكم
السناتور براون السناتور
ممثل بوكر جاكي هل أنت هنا
حيث جاكي لم أعتقد
أنها ستكون هنا للمساعدة في جعل هذا
واقعًا مرة أخرى لأسألها
السؤال عن عضوة الكونغرس ، لست
متأكدًا من سبب لماذا مرة أخرى
بصراحة أعتقد أن ذكرى
عضو الكونجرس في التاريخ تتطلب بعض
الوضوح هنا ،
هل يمكنك أن تشرح أين تم ارتكاب الخطأ
هل كان الرئيس
مرتبكًا كان شيئًا مكتوبًا في
الملقن الذي لم تتعرف عليه ،
هل يمكنك مساعدتنا فقط في فهم ما
أعنيه أنك تقفز إلى الكثير من
الاستنتاجات ،
لا أسمعك ستيفن أنا أجيب
على السؤال الذي تقفز فيه إلى
الكثير من الاستنتاجات.  فقط أجبت على
السؤال إذا كان هذا هو
الحال ، لكنت قد ذكرت ذلك الحق ،
لقد ذكرت بوضوح أه ما
أوضحته للتو أه ما قلته هو أنها
كانت فوقي
وأنه سيرى عائلتها في غضون يومين فقط
يوم الجمعة لتكريمها لتكريم عملها
على رأس أولوياتها كل يوم تقريبًا ،
لكنني لا أبحث عنه على أي حال
عندما توقع فاتورة لجون لينون
لينون  كرئيس ، ثم يمكننا إجراء
هذه المحادثة ، حسنًا ، تفضل ، تفضل ،
تفضل ، عفوا